hi I'm Bo and I am going to show you how
to program a magic trick using nodejs
and MongoDB we are going to be using
these free code camp playing cards so
free code camp has a some playing cards
that you can actually buy so the link is
in the description if you want to get
your own copy but check out these
playing cards each card has a different
programmer a different important
programmer from history these are pretty
cool we got Larry well Adel Goldberg and
there's all sorts of different
programmers from history so I'm about to
perform the magic trick on my friend and
then we'll show you how it works and
then this is going to be a coding
tutorial I'll show you how to code this
trick using nodejs in MongoDB and we'll
deploy it to Heroku so let's see the
trick okay Kayla I have a card trick to
show you
okay I have these three code camp
playing cards alright and what I'm going
to do is have you pick any card that you
want okay just pick any card are you
sure okay what Caillou can you can tell
it you can tell everyone with the card
it what is it Richard Stallman a six of
clubs okay so it's six and it's a six of
spades yes okay so this is what we're
gonna do I made a program that's going
to be able to figure out what your card
is so yeah I have never I pad here
there's a fun kid case and I'm gonna
have you go to a website are you at that
type in the URL it's gonna be if you see
an yeah so you can type in the word any
car to aan Y CA Rd
and they're gonna do dot okay and then
go type of Heroku app you spell it
APR 18 2014 6 of spades
codeine it's like magic ok one thing you
may not have noticed my wife was in the
background and she was typing something
into her phone so this trick actually
you do need to have an accomplice that
can help out with this trick it doesn't
have to be right next to you you could
actually have someone far away if as
long as they can hear a recording of
what's happening but my wife was
actually putting in some information
into the website that gets stored on the
MongoDB database so then when my friend
went to the certain website with his
name it would not have worked with any
other name just his name specifically it
gets the data from the MongoDB database
so we can display the card that he chose
so let's go into the computer the code
editor so you can see how this works
first I'll show you how this any card
app works and then we'll start coding it
from scratch so we went to the URL if we
this is the route URL and then slash
secret this is where your person that's
helping you the website that they go to
so we're gonna enter a name I'll put Bo
that's my name and then if they say
whatever the card that the spectator
picks your helper is gonna go to for
let's say it's 4 of spades and then just
do submit now if we go to slash Bo we
should see 4
of spades but if we go to another name
like Quincy it'll just show not found
because it hasn't been entered into the
database and then also if you ever
wanted to delete everything we can just
go to delete all and the database reset
so now if I go to a bow it will not show
anything so it's a pretty simple app but
it can make a pretty impressive magic
trick when you go to perform it on
somebody so let's start building this
from scratch I'll go over into Visual
Studio code I've already created a
folder and then inside the folder that
is called any card I created a server
j/s another thing I have already done is
copied in this cards directory and this
just has an image of each card that can
be chosen by the spectator so you can
get a link to all these files right in
the description of the video here so let
me go back into our server file server
j/s and we are going to start coding but
actually before we start coding let's
set up some things since we are going to
be using node and we are going to be
using some packages I'm going to have to
set up a package that JSON JSON file so
I have this terminal opened down at the
bottom here and I'm going to do MPM and
knit - why and that's going to just
create my package a JSON file and I just
says yes to all the questions so now
that we've done that we can install some
things so do MPM install we'll be using
let's see Express body parser and
MongoDB so we just install that and now
we can start working on our server so
the first things we're just going to
require a lot of things at the beginning
okay we got all this initial setup done
let's go over this we've required
Express now this is a web server for
nodejs so it makes it easier to set up a
web server pretty quickly and then we
are going to be using the web server and
app here you'll see that later path this
is going to allow us to get the the
route path that a file is stored in on
our inter directory you'll see that in a
second then we have body parser this
extracts the entire body portion of an
incoming request stream and exposes it
on the wreck top body as something
that's easier to interface with what it
basically means is it makes it much
simpler to deal with data coming in from
forms and we have a form right on our
page so will you know about MongoDB
we're gonna be Ankur interacting with a
MongoDB database so we get this
client for MongoDB now this URL or
actually let's call this URI
and we can even I'm gonna just put this
all capital I capitalized so this is our
an environment variable which is where
our database is so we're actually gonna
set this up right and right in Heroku
this environment variable in the MongoDB
database so we'll do that later
and then our server is going to be
running on this port which is you
they're gonna be at this environment
variable or port 5,000 and I'm gonna add
one more variable will do a Const and
this is going to be the DB name the
database name and this is going to be an
environment variable so to process that
E&V dot DB name these will be set in
Heroku later so now we need to include
our middleware the body part or
middleware
so I'll do app dot use and then I'll
just pass in body parser that URL
encoded and then I have to put extended
false
and then one more thing with the body
parser now this body partial things that
you are uncoated and the json this is
something to help the forms will be able
to send the form data correctly to our
server now we'll create our first route
so to app get this is going to be an
HTTP GET request which is the normal
type of request when you go to a website
we're doing a get request so the route
is going to be slash secret so if a
person goes to the secret route that's
where they can get the form to enter the
card that the user has chosen we will
make this request aro function so after
we go to that route then is going to run
this function here and it's going to do
res dot send file and it's going to send
our HTML file we're gonna do path dot
join underscore Dru name secret HTML so
what this is doing is it's finding the
the root directory where we're storing
our all of our files and then adding
secret dot HTML on the end now actually
I already created that file so when you
go to slash secret and it's going to
send this file to the user and it's this
file right here now I'll put a link in
the description where you can get this
file directly I didn't think I should
just type all this in because it's a lot
of repetitive stuff but this is the form
that a user will see and you can see the
form action is to post to slash secret
which is the same route that we're on
but weird this would be a post request
and
sort of a get request to the slash
secret and you can see they can input
their name and then it's a drop down box
for the number and then a drop down box
for the suit and then a submit button so
let's go back over to our server here
so our first route is slash secret and
our second route is also slash secret
but it's going to be a post request and
this is where after someone fills in the
form they will submit the form data to
this route here so secret and it's going
to start off the same so I'll do a rec
res and this is not just gonna be a
one-line thing this is going to be
multiple lines so once someone submits
the data it's going to have to connect
to the database so that's this is
where we're gonna use the client
and we'll connect and we'll pass in the
URI variable because that's the where
the database is that we're connecting to
and then I have to pass in this flag use
new URL parser now this is just
something you have to do because things
were updated and now there's this new
URL parser that's important to use so
pretty much all new databases they could
have connecting to you're gonna pass
then this new URL parser and then we'll
put in the function so the result will
have a error and then we'll have the
database that we get as a result of
connecting to this and what we're gonna
do here is check if there's an error so
if there's an error then we'll just do
something simple we're just going to
console that log it but if there's not
an error then we're going to get access
to the database so Const DB and then
reminds me actually this DB should
really be a client and then we access
the DB down here the database constabie
equals client dot DB and then we pass in
the database name which is just our
environment variable and then we have to
get access to the collection of the
database so I'll do a collection equals
DB dot collection names
now the collection that we're calling
names you can call it anything here and
the first time you access it it's going
to create it if it doesn't already exist
and now we have to create our entry that
we're going to put into the database so
I'll do Const entry and we're going to
have a name which is just going to be
rec name dot two lower case so from the
request the HTTP requests we're going to
get the body and then the name because
remember we're passing in a name and a
card or a name and a number so we get
the name here and then we convert it to
lowercase and that really should be a
comma here and then the card is going to
just be a wreck body number and so
remember we pass a number in a suit and
we're going to combine the number in the
suit to the card name that corresponds
to our files and our cards directory so
we'll do a number plus of so it'd be
like three of Hearts so the next part is
going to be rec body that suit
okay now we've created an entry and we
just have to insert that so I'll do a
collection dot insert one because we're
entering one item into the collection
and then we're gonna pass in entry
that's entry we just created and then
we'll have a function here so this is an
arrow function air and result and in
this if there is an error then we can
just console dot log the error
else we'll send something back read send
and we'll just and send back a string
inserted into database so that they'll
just show up on the screen that string
and then we have to make sure to close
the database so the DB dot close at the
end here now we have to create our other
route so remember the other route is if
someone goes to the URL and then puts a
person's name at the end so we'll do
apt-get and this is where we can put a
variable right in the route so I'll do
slash and then call them / Ram and then
I'll put a star or asterisk here and
this becomes a variable so a route with
a variable at the end and then we have
our function rec res this arrow function
here and we can do something with the
information we get from from the route
so let's figure out what name was passed
in as this parameter here so we'll do
Const name equals rec that you URL that
slice so this URL we're getting it as a
full section here and we are going to
slice it
just get the index one of the URL which
will be the name and then we can do to
lowercase and then once we have the name
we can connect to the database again so
client and it's just like before
where we're going to connect we're gonna
pass in the URI we are going to put in
this flag here use new or a new URL
parser true and then we have our
function so in the function we're gonna
have error and then we're gonna have a
reference to the client and let me
scroll this a little bit here so if
there is an error
we'll just console that log it just like
before else we can do something with
that name so first we'll get it will get
a little sore the database in a variable
so DB equals client dot DB and we'll
pass in the DB name and then we need the
collection this is just like before
equals DB that collection names and
remember if someone puts the word delete
all in the URL we want to delete the
whole database so we're gonna check if
the name equals equals equals delete all
and then if it does
then we'll do a collection dot remove
and if we just pass in an empty object
this is going to remove everything and
it's going to delete everything in the
collection and then we'll just send a
message which is just database reset so
that should appear on screen so we know
that that happened else so for any other
name here we'll do collection dot find
so we want to find the item in the
collection of the name so we're going to
pass in name : name so the first name is
the key in the database but this name is
actually the variable from here so if
the name of the database equals the name
we passed in well we're going to convert
that to an array because there could be
multiple entries for that name and we
want every single every single entry
that has that name to be returned as an
array so we can do something with it
here so do err result and of arrow
function here and again we'll just do if
the air if there isn't air then we'll
just console dot log the air else or
else if result dot length now this if
the length is 1 or more this evaluates
to true if the length is 0 it evaluates
to false so if there is at least one
result then we're going to do this
Const card we're gonna get what the card
was that's associated with that person
result result dot length
minus 1.so result that link this is an
array index result that link -1 is the
last item in that array and then we want
the card name of the item and then we
just have to add plus dot P&G because
that will be the file name so now we
have the file name of the card and we'll
just do res dot send file but instead of
seeing an HTML file we can send a P&V
file so we'll do path dot join
underscore underscore jure name this is
just like before to get the directory
the actual full path to that card that
PNG file so we have a card directory let
me get this in a string here and then we
will add the card oh I need to get rid
of this in semicolon and put it here
okay cuz we're joining all those things
together into one path else if there's
no results if the result dot length
equals 0 then we'll send a status of 404
and then the final thing we have to do
is DB dot close now let's see what I did
oh this is supposed to be a curly brace
here so that's a curly brace and this is
a curly brace so we created all of our
variable names and then we put in our
middleware then we have our routes here
in the final thing we need to do is have
our database start listening for people
to connect to those routes so we'll do
app dot listen and then we'll pass in
the port
that's the port number from our
variables up above console dot log
server listening on port so this message
will go to the screen so we know that
the server is now listening on that port
okay
now normally when you're gonna do a
project you're gonna set it up to work
with the local database before you start
using a database stored on another
server but we kind of skip that step of
trying to get this tested locally
because we are gonna go right to hosting
this on Heroku and using a database
that's right on Heroku first let me see
if there's any mistakes I have to fix oh
yeah this should actually be spelled
close here and then this word is number
ok I'll save and then we'll go over to
Heroku in the browser I'm already on the
page to create a new app in Heroku and
we're gonna call this any card which is
available now there can only be one of
each name so this name will be taken if
you're trying to follow along you'll
have to pick a different name but I'll
do create app ok now that I've created
app this actually tells instructions on
what to do so we want to login to Heroku
and do Heroku login now press any key to
open up in the browser to login so I'll
do that
and I can just click login so now we're
logged in to Heroku you may actually
have to download installed Heroku CLI
I'd already done that so we'll look at
this it says initialize a git repository
and so we'll go back over here and do
get Annette
we got a nougat repository and it says
to run this line right here Heroku get
remote so we're setting Heroku as a
remote host for our git repository and
the next thing it says to do is just do
a git add okay before we add everything
we are going to add a get ignore file
and ignore our node modules directory so
I'll do new file and do get egg noir and
then we'll just add node modules so now
I'll do a git add and then we can go to
this one that get commit am we're just
going off of these directions here even
though I think a lot of you probably
already know the different commands here
but we'll do the first commit and the
last thing it recommends doing is get
push Heroku master so we'll run that
okay now that that's done we are going
to add our database we can do that right
from the head command line with Heroku
add-ons create lab okay we have
one final thing we need to do which is
to make sure our environmental variables
are all set up so I'm in the Heroku
dashboard on the settings tab and if I
click reveal config VARs now the convict
bought these config VARs are the
environmental variables now this is
automatically put in for us when we set
up lab it has the MongoDB URI as
this URI here we still need to create
the DB name so the DB name is actually
right in this URI I just have to copy
this section
right here now it will be different for
you than for me because this is all
randomly generated so I'm going to copy
the section between these slashes and
that : I'll copy it and just paste in
the value here and then click Add now if
I've done everything correctly our apps
should work now so let's give it a test
okay now I'm to my app URL any card on
Heroku app comm slash secret and if I
type in a name here and then I can
choose the three of spades if I click
Submit here and we have an error okay
well I'm going to copy my Heroku logs
/us tailed or - - tail I can put it into
my command line over here I'll paste
this in and then I can see the Heroku
logs and it should tell us what the
problem was TV that close is not a
function now did I spell something wrong
here oh okay I see what we did wrong
okay so this is a client here so down
here when I when we do DB dot close it
should be client that close and then
same with down here client that should
fix it so if I save this and then I'm
going to go out of this get add now get
commit message update server and then
I'll go to the git push Heroku master
okay I'm gonna go back over to my
browser and load this again type in my
name bow-bow and then
ace of diamonds submit this insert into
database so if
I go to bow here it should show ace of
diamonds it worked now if I should go to
another name like Quincy not found so
any other name is going to be not found
if I do delete all database reset if I
go to secret again it will go to this
page again so I can make this magic
trick work all I have to do is ask
someone to pick a card and then I have
my co-conspirator or my helper would
type in their name like Quincy and then
put the number maybe it was the seven of
spades
click Submit and then when I have my
person would go to the URL slash their
name it's going to show the card they
chose so everything worked so you can
try this out with your own deck of cards
or you can purchase the free code camp
deck of cards like I said the link is in
the description well thanks for watching
and remember use your code for good